um i got a i got a guy here that's got a
question about marrying his ltr and
having kids while maintaining frame
uh i see oh he's back now okay let's add
him back in
all right phil so you got an ltr and
you're talking about getting married and
having kids in frame so what's the
question for us tonight
yeah so um i've been in this ltr for
about um a year and a half now i've
known her for longer
maybe two and a half years
um
we are thinking about actually getting
married
married because uh we live in south
america okay and it's not a very rich
country
and she has
a italian citizens citizenship and
passport
so
by getting married i can access also
that passport and we can move to
uh europe um maybe germany
or um
we haven't decided quite uh yet which
country
um
so yeah my question is basically
do you guys think it would be a smart
move to uh get married
basically because of this so uh so i
mean the first question i got for you is
what south american country
a uruguay uruguay okay and why are you
doubting it because i mean like if you
didn't doubt it then you wouldn't be on
here asking us this question so why are
you doubting this marriage
well
when starting the relationship there was
a couple of red flags um were they
she
she had previously been
also in a long relationship before being
with me
and um
it was sort of like an abusive
kind of relationship
and she she's got some you know some
baggage
that she brought on with that coming out
of that relationship
but she's working through it and
it's been better lately
at the beginning it was a little bit
tough
for me uh but um
it's a lot better now i must say she's
she's really hot she's she's nice but
she's got sometimes she she you know she
she gets a little bit jumpy sometimes
and i believe it's because of that
um
that overall
we get along really good how old are you
and how old is she
i'm 31 she's 29.
does she have any kids already
no
and you met her in your country right
yes we actually met on tinder
about four years ago and then we started
talking uh through other of social media
yeah and we finally
met
maybe two and a half years ago or three
and uh let me ask this question do you
want to have kids
actually you know what i did not i was
the kind of guy that would
think i never wanted to have kids
and um
when we started dating i actually
started thinking about the idea that
maybe you know what i maybe i did want
to have one or two kids
i give my mom
grandkids that i i know she would love
that and actually i do get along pretty
well with with kids and i i like being
around kids
um but i didn't dated her for about
yeah we've been dating for about a year
and a half now and how long has she been
exclusive with you
um
[Music]
a little bit longer than that maybe
i would say
about
18 months or so okay so let me just make
sure that that is clear so you
understand so you've been dating her for
a year and a half
she's been sexually exclusive to you for
18 months is what you're saying well a
little bit longer than that maybe
yeah i would say
um
before we started dating like officially
dating
she
she was already exclusive and i kind of
know that because i did a little bit of
research
um maya and i don't want to get into
details but i did some research on you
did some recon okay behind the scenes
got it yeah okay so we understand dude
is that what you're saying what's that
so when you first you said you first
started dating her she was already
exclusive what do you mean by that she
was already with somebody else
yeah when we started dating and uh
maybe i'm not
saying this right when we started our
officially
like relationship
like being boyfriend and girlfriend so
to speak
um
she had already been sexually exclusive
to you before you guys became official
basically so why don't you guys throw
some clarifying questions at him before
you offer some feedback what happens if
it doesn't work out do you get deported
well actually
um i do have to wait
through to i i believe it's two years
i um if we live in the in the
uh european union for two years i
already get the sit-in citizenship once
we're married um if we stay in uruguay
we have to wait three years but the plan
is to move immediately
um
and once i get it the citizenship that's
it i mean even if we get divorced i
don't lose it
so you're banking on this working out
for at least two years
yeah exactly
hopefully i mean honestly hopefully i
will
i think she's um
good material for being a mom i i i
would like to think
that she would be the one that would
have my kids
and she's got really good also jeans i
believe she's going to remain being
smoking hot for at least
10 or even more years no no no dude dude
you don't have a time machine you can't
look into the future and predict that i
mean like the closest predictor that
you're ever gonna get is looking at her
mom
that's it and even that's not a
guarantee okay so just you know relax
with the whole i think she's gonna be
hot forever you know story that you're
telling yourself
i just want you to turn off the
afterburners for a sec
when you knew her before you started
dating what was that relationship was it
platonic were you a beta orbiter yeah
why are you doing something for you guys
today were you were you the nice guy
that was there for her when she was in
an abusive relationship yeah she's 29 so
you know you know living in latin
america she knows kind of what i was
wondering about she she's got baby
rabies
if a woman's 30 in latin america she's
not getting married by the latin guys so
what's what's the deal there you know
this you're a neuro guy
well
look when
before we officially started dating um i
was actually kind of i don't want to say
alpha but i was kind of the guy let
would be like texting her and she if she
was kind of like i don't know maybe or
so i would just
bounce like and do my thing and i think
that that's what got her attracted
because she wasn't used to that she was
used to getting a lot of attention
and uh honestly i i've al always had
options
so
i would never
kind of chase
chicks
and then when did you guys start banging
that's what i want to know when when did
you guys meet and then when did you guys
actually start banging
we we probably uh started banging i
think it was on the
second or third date
[Music]
around things right when did you meet
when did you meet her because i thought
there was this period
where you had known her but yeah he did
mention about four years ago is what was
when he first came across her on tennis
yeah
what's going on with that
we came across on tinder about four
years ago
and
um basically
it's kind of what so so pill
not pill phil let me just get you the
point so what so what paul's asking you
is you've been dating her for the last
year and a half but you met her four
years ago
why did you wait like two and a half
years to you know start dating her and
be a couple
basically when we matched on tinder she
was actually not done yet with her ex
she was going away
hold on a sec so she was on tinder while
she was still with her ex
no
she was she was going through a rough
badge they kind of hold on a second hold
on a second hold on a second you just
said that she was like
and she met you while she was still with
her ex
well
they had kind of split then they
went by okay dude this is not going to
work if you're not going to be honest
with us man
the only acceptable answer to richard's
question was because oh i was too busy
banging chicks i forgot about her and
then she was just there like right yeah
you might take that as an answer so did
you so so for two and a half years
she was with the crazy x and you were
the beta and waiting then is what you're
saying
i was actually not waiting to be honest
with you i would text her once in a
while and see if she kind of want to
hang out if she didn't then i would go
do my thing with someone else
i i have a clarifying question who's
pushing the europe move because i've
done the international marriage before i
married a colombian girl and everything
was great when she lived with me in
latin america the minute we got in the
u.s and we went and lived in a city
where her family was i was in her frame
now and all of a sudden oh i'm an
independent woman you don't tell me how
to do that we we were walking down the
streets like oh i don't need to hold
your hand i'm like what are you talking
about
if you're going to her country you're
going to be with her family her culture
her language all that you're going to be
in her frame 100 is she pushing that
move or are you pushing it for better
opportunity
well look actually she's she's from she
was born and raised here in uruguay her
almost her family from uruguay is she
got the citizenship because her
grandparents were from italy yeah
italian so
basically but i am you got a point
pointer i am kind of a little bit scared
that even though um i am going to be a
little in her frame i i might be in her
frame if you know
i'm depending on this citizenship by
staying married
so i have a question for you too another
one um so you
didn't really think about having kids as
something that you would necessarily
want and then you changed your mind yeah
so what was the catalyst for that mind
change because she's hot and has nice
boobies
for that mind change
and so dude here's the thing man because
people love
to
yeah and do what rich just said and yeah
they love to kind of delude themselves a
bit right
is that you like this girl
and you she wasn't picking you
and then she picked you later
that's okay whatever that's a red flag
then she's
says i want all these things in life
and you said jeez
that sounds great i'm gonna do all these
things because she wants them
right now it's not looking like you're
in a frame or that she's in your frame
it's looking like it's the other way
around yeah that's a date that's going
to get worse when you leave uruguay and
go to europe
she'll hold that over your head too if
you want out of that relationship she'll
be like oh you have to wait for two
years she will hold you hostage
have you have you read my book phil
no i do have to read it yeah if you
can't get it through amazon you can get
it through
bookdepository.com they ship anywhere in
the world i know that amazon doesn't
doesn't ship or like let you download
kindle in certain places you need to
read it
um
you don't even have to like read the
whole book i mean at least here let me
get it over here and i'll throw it up on
the screen like at least get get the
damn uh
red flag chapter where's my freaking
ticker there we go
your red flag trap is still free right
yeah it's it's free so if you just go to
entrepreneursandcars.com forward slash
red dash flags you can download it for
free i mean you're gonna get prompted to
go on my email list i don't spam it it's
only good [ __ ] that i send out but at
least read that as a very beginner the
other thing that i would say is slow the
hell down here
okay because you haven't given this
enough time to really size it up to see
what your place in this relationship
looks like and whether or not she's like
you know a good fit for you whether or
not she's really going to be a a
compliment i mean you've already talked
about a couple of red flags but the way
that you're describing where you are
right now and where where things are
going i think you're holding some stuff
back if i'm being honest um you know
because we like to paint things over and
pretty up and let's throw some rainbows
and butterflies and sell it to these
guys and see if i can get them to tip
their hat that's always the case right
guys never never give us the whole
you know nine yards we're only getting
like the tip of the iceberg so slow it
down take some time to like better a
little longer apply some chaos to the
relationship you know see how she
responds to chaos does she throw hissy
fits if she doesn't get her way does she
get violated together yeah nobody's
already been to italy yeah like have you
traveled to italy like if you've been to
germany have you seen what it's like
i yeah i've traveled to europe she
hasn't together no but like together is
what he's doing airbnb for a month and
then just
go
let me ask i think
i think probably the most important
question here we're focusing on the on
the on the gal charles just posted
something hilarious in the chat by the
way and uh he brings up a good point
where it's like
hey look is is italy where you really
want to go
because i i've been to italy a zillion
times it's not exactly it's not actually
the bastion of economic development like
it's just not it's great you know
what it's like europe for the most part
is not right now either no yes i know i
don't want to go to
come to mexico being from south america
like you you have you'll have your pick
of women like why would you want to go
to germany italy like
i can't remember the country you
mentioned but why
basically because of the income um
in income here in uruguay is really low
you've got a job right like you've got a
job
okay so you're not an entrepreneur
no unfortunately not yet
let's back up one second here phil
you're gonna spend an inordinate amount
of time like two to three years to get
the citizenship go through all that
nonsense
i would sit down and say where is the
best place where i can make the most
money and have the best
cost of living that may be here in the
united states houston's actually a good
time for that
for that reason i went to houston for
that reason did it three years out yeah
it's great so
i would i'd rather see you sit down and
say okay how do i have the best life
possible and it and i'm gonna i'm just
gonna assume it's probably not italy
now all of a sudden this whole
relationship thing this relationship
conversation changes immediately
so that's when i'd sit down if i'd
encourage you to do anything it's like
all right what do i really want to
accomplish in my life maybe it's to get
here to the united states
maybe that's where to come to texas
right i'm here in texas so if that's the
case then now you're having a
conversation with her hey babe i'm going
to texas i want to make more money i
want to be more successful it's the land
of opportunity this is where i'm going
and you're actually flipping the script
daughter and then you see what her
reaction is right things start to ch
because if you're gonna spend two or
three years trying to figure this italy
thing out let's spend two or three years
going somewhere it's got better
opportunities you should be taking the
lead you should have a clear version of
where you're going i wish you would but
i don't think that's gonna happen here
so
that's where you want to be here
like your income in uruguay how much do
you make on an annual basis there
um
sorry like a better way for me to phrase
a question might be like in what
percentile is your income in uruguay
like are you in the top
80 percent top like where do you sit
no
not even near
so why are you going to be good enough
for with another job in another country
somewhere else in a long-term basis
i mean like you're not the best version
of yourself right now
no one the title of the show is chase
excellence not women but what are you
doing to put yourself first mental point
of origin and like level yourself up
well what uh what i believe
europe would give me uh would be a
better chance at getting a lot
like an income uh like a decent income
and uh
you can't go next door to chile don't
don't they have a pretty nice robust
growing economy or i know we're all
going to suffer worldwide don't worry
about it
so let's see what's happening here bill
have you have you like sat down and
compared notes on like what the
different requirements are to move into
other countries
this is one of two questions i have for
you
like you know naturalization
requirements income levels like there
are certain countries that you want to
immigrate to they're not going to take
you unless you have a certain amount of
net worth like bermuda the second
question is
is more of a scenario and
you know this might be
something you need to think about rather
than answer now but okay let's say
you're in italy you're in germany pick
your country it's a year and a half into
that two-year period and you have a kid
with uh with your ltr
and you realize that you two [ __ ]
hate each other's guts what are you
gonna do
are you gonna
it's all sunshine and rainbows yeah like
i thought living in italy would be cool
too but if i had a infant and a woman
that i'm married to who i can't stand
all the charms of italy are going to
burn away pretty quickly
yeah your kids literally on the other
side of the world if you go home yeah
like what i'm saying here dude is like
you barely like like this thing is brand
spanking new and it's not like you know
you were her first choice four years ago
she was just testing waters back then
and happened to pick you two and a half
years later year and a half it's nothing
dude
how long you should be vetting women
that you're going to be with she's she's
at her epiphany phase right like she's
starting to have the baby she wants to
have kids you know you look like a good
choice what do you do for a living like
what's your profession
i work for amazon um i basically do
tech support for amazon okay
so like like you'd be doing something
similar in europe then you'd be doing
tech support for another like large
yes but i would be charging
triple
or four times
the cost of living is also four times
higher in europe too right
it's going to be higher yes but
not as much as the difference between
wages i would be able to at least save
some money okay
man
get a sale
that's what i was thinking yeah yeah
find a tech company and offer to do
sales for them they always need sales
guys and you speak english well i was
just in el salvador for six months
building the sales team like you you'd
be perfect for a role like that those
guys make as much money as i do all
right so to be fair to you know the
other guys waiting to hop on and i've
got a bunch of super chats here waiting
so you've been given some good advice
phil i've i would suggest slowing get
the hell down
taking some time to vet at least at a
bare minimum read the red flag chapter
that's there below you can get that for
free if you don't get the book then get
it too but get your head around what it
is that you're dealing with because i
think you're basically marching in with
slaughterhouse the way that you're
describing it and i think everybody i
mean here guys like is he marching into
a slaughterhouse thumbs up
phil i've i've been there and i wish i
could go back and save you brother
thumbs up
listen to your intuition you already
know the answer slow down man all right
thank you guys all right see ya
you